Republicans are now accusing President
Joe Biden of bribery with absolutely
zero evidence Marjorie Taylor green uh
Sean Hannity Chuck Grassley Senators
members of Congress right-wing media
they're all saying we might even be
getting to impeachment of Biden now oh
what exactly did he do well we don't
know what's the evidence well we don't
have any yeah let me explain to you the
back story of what's going on Joe Biden
Accused by whistleblower of bribery
scheme with foreign National this is
reported by Newsweek and many others a
pair of top republicans in Congress this
is the base of the story a pair of top
republicans in Congress issued a
subpoena for records They say might and
the word might is doing a lot of work
here might detail a criminal scheme
involving then Vice President Joe Biden
and a foreign National
the White House says it's unfounded and
that the claims are motivated by
political bias when you look at who's at
the center of this it's Iowa Republican
senator Chuck Grassley and Kentucky
Republican representative James Comer
James Comer for months now probably
years in fact has been saying Biden's
guilty of what well we don't know yet
but he's guilty and now they've got
something they have an alleged
whistleblower making a claim that as of
yet is completely unsubstantiated now
they're going to they've issued a
subpoena they're going to look for
evidence and as I've said before I'm
going to speak very clearly and slowly
here if there is evidence
investigate if the investigate points to
crimes prosecute and if there is a
conviction sentence that applies to Joe
Biden it applies to Hunter Biden it
applies to Hillary Obama Trump
that is my perspective on all of this
but we have to at some point say
do we have any evidence whatsoever
for what is right now an allegation from
a whistleblower the answer is no but
that doesn't stop all sorts of the usual
clowns from coming out and saying it's
time we're going to impeach him now you
might say David there really aren't
credible news outlets taking this
seriously right now and that's right
because there is no evidence at this
point in time so let's start with
Marjorie Taylor green she appeared on
Lindell TV's Frank speech war room
yeah I I don't know
um she says uh we're we're getting close
to impeachment now well this is where
we're truth Lincoln
money to make real policy decisions uh
on behalf of the United States it's pay
to play this is a true crime and this
was Joe Biden when he was vice president
of the United States when Joe Biden took
a money payment from a foreign National
in exchange for policy decisions
understand there's no evidence for any
of this he was vice president
will be impeached and that's the
evidence that we've under we have cut we
have now understand there's no evidence
there's just an alleged whistleblower
that's all there is found out under her
in only a few months a few months time
we were able to do this they've
undercovered it it's not even a question
of uncovering it they've undercovered it
God for the American people that voted
to put Republicans in the majority and
give us the gavel so that we could have
subpoena power to go after the Biden
crime family and everything they've done
to sell out this country now remember
that Marjorie Taylor green was drafting
articles for impeaching Joe Biden before
any of this stuff came out to begin with
and now they have something to latch on
to Ted Cruz of course a Bastion of
Sanity sober uh reasoning and and uh
moral
being an upstanding moral citizen Ted
Cruz appeared on Sean Hannity's
propaganda program on Fox News and they
are also talking about impeaching Biden
without having any evidence or substance
whatsoever from Grassley and comer yeah
and they're saying that they believe the
doj and the FBI possess an unclassified
fd-1023 that describes that an alleged
criminal scheme involving they're not by
the way alleged is doing a lot of work
here they're not even all they're saying
is they have a whistleblower claiming it
that's all then Vice President Biden and
a foreign National relating to the
exchange of money for a policy decision
uh that would be a high crime of
misdemeanor win it Senator it it
absolutely would in fact it doesn't have
to be a high crime or misdemeanor
because the Constitution specifies that
impeachment lies for treason bribery or
other high crimes investigators bribery
is explicitly noted they're fine in the
Constitution and and I got to say the
evidence not only against Hunter Biden
but the evidence against Joe Biden being
complicit and profiting from this
corruption is growing and growing and
growing every week on my podcast I've
verdict with Ted Cruz I've walked
listeners through yeah that's a hell of
a podcast by the way so they're talking
about impeachment they've seen no
evidence either Pastor I'm sorry uh
Senator Josh Hawley not Pastor Josh
Hawley Senator Josh Hawley admits he
hasn't actually seen any of the evidence
but it should still be up to Democrats
to prove Biden is innocent which isn't
exactly the way I remember burden of
proof working in the United States you
know senator who do we think
I think that we knew the Chinese
connection and all that but this isn't
this is something new do you have any
information on that no I do not
that and the funny thing is that's the
answer for all of these guys I actually
don't have any information but we
definitely need to impeach Biden
information on what the whistleblowers
has alleged in terms of the specific
substantive allegations right other than
that there is documentation that the FBI
has and I just say again to those
Democrats out there screaming about how
Joe Biden is innocent Joe Biden hasn't
done anything well fine then show us
what you know show us what the evidence
is in the allegations don't be afraid of
what the facts are there you go so Josh
Hawley making the case that he doesn't
have anything but it's up to Democrats
to demonstrate innocence
um then Chuck Grassley did also appear
on Fox News Chuck Grassley is one of the
main people here uh Chuck Grassley and
James Comer issuing The subpoena here to
the alleged whistleblower for the
allegations that they are making about
okay
um he is pressed about evidence and he
says well we have to wait we're
wondering exactly what this is all about
according to a press release that was
set up by James Commerce offices as the
information provided by a whistleblower
raises concerns that then Vice President
Biden allegedly engaged in a bribery
scheme with a foreign National it goes
on to say the American people need to
know if President Biden sold out the
United States to make money for himself
Senator Grassley and I will seek the
truth to ensure accountability for the
American people well that really what's
our appetite is to exactly what what
this is all about does this have to do
with 100 Biden's foreign business
dealing with Ukraine or China or is it
something else well I I guess basically
we we've got to wait to see what what
the document exactly says right but I
convinced that uh we've got to get this
detail and at this time the FBI needs to
explain whether it's accurate or not
yeah did they learn nothing from the
Dominion lawsuit and the
787.5 million dollar settlement over on
Fox News and then we have one from
Newsmax as well uh Newsmax is very very
concerned about this as I'm sure you can
imagine wait it says specifically the
release today that the vice president
may have altered policy
for money a primary scheme he may have
actually changed policy have you
narrowed it down to what policies or can
you at least tell me if you have what
area if you can't say specifically what
do you know about it sir uh Congressman
Fallon
well Greg that'll all come out I think
and it'll come out very soon just like
it's going to come out when with Trump's
health care plan is my guess all mine is
let's ask another question very simple
one what business what product or
service did the bidens ever provide yeah
there you go that's a real serious
question so listen as I've said before
do you have actual evidence against Joe
Biden Hunter Biden investigate uh turns
out there there were crimes it was
legitimate charge Biden charge Hunter
Biden charged Joe Biden I don't care I
don't care about defending anybody I
don't care about cults of personality
around any of these folks if Bernie
committed a crime charged Bernie okay
it's been years of this stuff and the
evidence is just on the tip of our
tongues be just beyond the reach of our
hands and yet it doesn't happen so I'm
reminded of when I think of this
whistleblower I'm reminded of remember
that I believe the guy's name was Tony
bobolinski or something like that who
was just going to deliver this Hammer
blow of uh evidence against
um I don't even remember who it was it
was going to clear Trump and all and
then he was interviewed like twice on
Fox and then you never heard from him
again because it was all completely
bogus if you've got the evidence let's
see it but are they really going to do
this for the rest of Joe Biden's term
the answer is absolutely yes they are I
love my car which is electric I love my
bicycle and I have to say that the
perfect medium in between is my electric
bike by Electric if you're looking to
spend about 800 or so on an e-bike
electric is where you want to go I've
tried e-bikes that cost seven thousand
dollars and electric delivers the same
performance and specs but at a much more
reasonable price point I take my
electric e-bike everywhere these days
I've almost completely ditched my
regular bike for now e-bikes are of
course better for the environment than
taking a car the e-bike gives you more
flexibility and range than a regular
bicycle you can go further you can see
more my e-bike is just my favorite form
of cardio at this point it comes fully
assembled to your door it includes a
bright LCD display seven speed gearing
five levels of pedal assist and a
powerful battery that's removable so you
can bring it indoors for charging it's
also fully foldable so I can put it in
the back of my car and they have
financing for as little as 73 bucks a
month go to electricebikes.com to learn
more explore all of the incredible
e-bike models they offer the link is
down below